[Music]
you are looking at some of these floats
rolling out to the streets of New
Orleans to celebrate Mardi Gras these
elaborate creations have long been part
of the Big Easy's pre-lenten celebration
and one family has been building them
for four generations
Jamie wax explores the tradition and the
history of these rolling works of arts
Mardi Gras New Orleans is billed as the
world's biggest free party and it comes
each year with some spectacular party
favors the costumes the beads and most
impressive of all the floats new designs
are already being made for next year's
carnival right now we've actually
already started props for next year
Barry Kern is the president and CEO of
Kern Studios the oldest and largest
creator of Mardi Gras floats in New
Orleans is it safe to say Mardi Gras is
in your blood absolutely I mean it's in
New Orleans blood mardi gras has been in
this city literally from the very first
days dating back to 1699 and moving
through 300 plus years of celebrations
the party continues and the Kern family
holds a key role in innovating and
preserving Mardi Gras parade traditions
all on public display here at Mardi Gras
world I don't think there's a production
line in terms of floats and parades
anywhere like what we do here I'm
talking about anywhere on earth and
technology has changed all of that too
yes we actually have a seven axis cuca
robot this robot is amazing it's
literally the same machine that they use
to mill the fuselage for the SpaceX
rocket but technology aside that's the
last piece for Farhat for Kern the
business is all about family for
generations of it this all really
started with your grandfather Roy trying
to use his artistic talent to survive
the Great Depression right but you
couldn't make money during the
Depression being an artist so literally
he became a sign writer and he would
paint signs on ships and freighters and
tugboats
barges in the river so he built the
float on the back of a garbage wagon for
the crew of alle in 1932 barry kern
credits his father with the vision that
brought the family business to the level
it's at today and my dad Blaine Kern who
they now called mr. Mardi Gras here in
town was a little boy and remembers
working with his dad and helping him out
and always helped his dad to build the
owl a parade over 50 parades filled the
streets of the Big Easy attracting
hundreds of thousands of people over the
to month-long celebration the floats are
paid for by the members of the cruise
these crews are like fraternities or
sororities or clubs and everybody's part
of these different crews and they pay to
be members to got probably 60,000
members of these carnival organizations
for 44 years mardi gras historian Arthur
Hardy has published the definitive
annual guide to carnival in New Orleans
we sat down over cafe brew lo or Devils
coffee at legendary Antoine's restaurant
what does Mardi Gras mean to you
personally it's the people you know it's
the feeling it's the Brotherhood in the
street everybody's equal at Mardi Gras
it doesn't matter color age you know
we're all coming together just to have a
good time it's what we do and when did
floats come into the picture really not
until the first real official Mardi Gras
parade in 1857 we started out with one
parade with two floats now in our Metro
era we have nearly 60 parades more than
1,100 floats it's probably the largest
celebration of its kind anywhere and in
the spirit of a celebration thrown for
the people by the people Hardy says
there's one thing you'll never see on a
Mardi Gras float in NOAA and one of the
most amazing things about it is that
it's not commercially sponsored the
shareholders of Mardi Gras the citizens
of New Orleans and it's actually a law
in New Orleans that you can't have
commercial signs or you know Pepsi on
the side of a float can't do it the
current party and everyone who was in
the city at the time there was one
particular year when the sight of the
floats rolling through the streets was
especially meaningful I remember
standing at those parades only months
after Katrina
and having people with tears rolling
down their faces what did that year mean
to you to get all Mardi Gras crews
running again just months after Katrina
when you literally have thousands of
people died tens of thousand people out
of their homes no one was thinking about
Mardi Gras so we knew that it was very
very important to have those parades for
many reasons I think that when we did it
and it happened I think everybody
understood why it needed to happen and
as New Orleans continues to build
rebuild and grow it's clear that the one
thing that weathers all storms is the
spirit of the people that call this
place home
I think genetically encoded in our DNA
this is how we celebrate it's joyful its
joyful and if if other people don't get
it that's their problem but we're gonna
do it forever I don't think we need to
justify let's just go celebrate and you
better believe it I'll see you in the
streets I'll see you in the streets
I should mention the young man you saw
walking next to Barry Kernan is his son
the fourth generation Fitz Kern and that
waiter preparing that great cafe brew
Lowe was Charles Carter one of the best
lawyers in the world at outed Antoine's
you know every one of them don't you and
you do too you know they know you by
name oh come on they know me for some
other reason that is not true but being
in New Orleans with you or some of the
best times I've ever had we have a good
time down there yeah whether were Bolin
or rock and roll